Everyone knows Batman as one of the flagship DC
Comics characters. The Dark Knight himself has
consistently ranked as one of the world's
most popular superheroes, rivaling -- and
often completely outperforming -- most of the
major figures of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"Who the hell are you supposed to be?"
As such, Bats often becomes part of a much
larger rivalry between two comic book giants,
but it's worth noting that this
conflict exists more in the heads
of fans than it does behind the
scenes -- where actors, creators,
and other talent often feel free to hop
between the DC and Marvel universes with ease.
For instance, the upcoming Warner Bros
film "The Batman," which reimagines the
Gotham City legend in an even darker light
than before, contains a number of actors
you will recognize. In fact, while you might
not realize it at first, three major actors
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe will be
shifting their gaze over to DC in this film.
The first of Marvel's movie-hopping
mega-stars actually didn't appear
until midway through the "Infinity Saga,"
and that's former Gollum actor Andy Serkis,
who is the newest actor to portray Bruce Wayne's
butler, Alfred Pennyworth in "The Batman."
In the MCU, Serkis' character is a
lot more villainous, as he played
Ulysses Klaue . Originally appearing in "Avengers:
Age of Ultron" before making his way into "Black
Panther," Klaue is the underground arms dealer
responsible for stealing vibranium from Wakanda.
While initially framed as the primary
antagonist of "Black Panther," a plot
twist sees him murdered by his associate,
Erik Killmonger, who betrays Klaue as a
means of entering Wakanda so that he may
challenge T'Challa and overthrow his rule.
The MCU isn't the only Marvel movie
property that Serkis is tied to.
He was also the director of "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage." As such,
he is the only actor on this list that has
direct connections to both DC and the MCU,
while also having a role to play in Sony's
line of "Spider-Man"-adjacent films.
Along with Serkis, Irish actor Barry Keoghan
also appears in both "The Batman" and the MCU,
though his entry into the latter
occurred much later than that of Serkis.
Keoghan is in "The Batman" as a
character who was kept secret.
Officially billed in pre-release
materials as "Officer Stanley Merkel,"
the character he actually plays in
the movie is much more mysterious.
We do know for certain that his MCU
character, the Eternal known as Druig,
is poised to continue appearing in future films.
In "Eternals," Druig -- with his power of mind
control -- becomes one of the few Eternals to
rebel against his Celestial creators, though it
remains to be seen how he and his surviving
family may be punished for their rebellion.
Finally, when it comes to joint actors shared
between the MCU and "The Batman," there is Jeffrey
Wright, who plays the famous James Gordon in the
latter. In most Batman stories, James Gordon is
well known as the Gotham City Police Commissioner
and father of Barbara Gordon, aka Batgirl.
He is one of Batman's closest and most trustworthy
collaborators, and the main reason why the GCPD
is often depicted as having a working relationship
with the Bat. Gordon is an instantly recognizable
role, to be sure, most famously embodied in past
films by Gary Oldman in the "Dark Knight" trilogy.
On the MCU side of things, however, Wright's
role is deceptively difficult to pick out,
if you don't pay attention. That's because
unlike the other actors listed, Wright's
role in the MCU is entirely done by voice, and
he (so far) has not appeared in any movies.
"This mission requires a team with the
perfect combination of skills and experience."
Instead, Wright's character of Uatu,
aka the Watcher -- a cosmic being that
observes events across the multiverse --
only occurs in the animated Disney+ series,
"What If...?" Despite Uatu's
efforts to remain impartial,
the series shows him eventually realizing that
a growing threat requires his intervention.
With "The Batman," however, we will finally see
Wright in a mainline, live-action comic book film.
It's an exciting step to see the actor take,
since Wright has been impressing critics since his
breakout role in "Basquiat" back in 1996 … also
starring another Commissioner Gordon, Gary Oldman.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.